the United States withdrew from the anti-missile defense treaty for a
long time persuaded not to do this, this is one
of the fundamental
fundamental security treaties
;  there are launchers m
to 41 on which you can install
tomahawks, that is, these are no longer
anti-missiles, but strike systems that
will cover our territory for
thousands of kilometers, but isn’t it a threat
for us to imagine that Ukraine
is a member of NATO,
crammed with weapons, there are modern
strike systems as well  how in Poland and
Romania who will interfere and
start operations
in Crimea now I’m not even talking about the Donbass,
this is sovereign Russian territory, the
question is closed for us in this sense,
imagine that Ukraine is a NATO country and
starts these military operations, we should
fight with the NATO bloc, but it
seems to me  that the same connected
pieces  ata not so much care about the
security of ukraine,
although maybe they think about it, they need to be
somewhere in the background, but the most
important thing is that their task is to contain the development of
russia,
that's what's the matter in this sense
, ukraine itself is just a tool to
achieve this goal, it can be done in
different ways  dragging us into
some kind of armed conflict and
forcing, among other things, our allies in
Europe to impose against us the very
tough sanctions that they are talking about
today in the United States, drag
Ukraine into NATO, set up strike
weapon systems there and stimulate which
middendorfs
ate the dam or the Crimea to resolve the issue
by force of arms and thus
still drag us into an armed conflict,
wanting to avoid such a negative
development of the situation, we want to avoid
it, we need to really
take into account the interests of all countries,
including Russia, and find a solution to
this problem